hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute eine runde rocket league in
minecraft spiel das ganze allerdings
nicht alleine sondern zusammen
freunde wir sind hier bei rocket liegen
hallo ich bin heute rocket league in
minecraft vom mister gar etwa findet
link dazu zählten besitzt hallo wir
spielen rocket liege meinte schon
tausend mal gesagt das ist eine map von
mister carretto ich bin jetzt gerade im
roten team weil ich auf dieser seite
steht schon ein rotes auto das in rotes
auto alter meiner hand irritiert mich
echt ein bisschen und alles so komisch
an blinken man kann über diese dinge
halt drüber fertig zeigt mit meinem
finger auf den bildschirm kommen kann
über diese teile drüber fahren wo ich
jetzt über fahrer dann seht ihr links
das stop ich muss mein chat größer
machen so was sie jetzt im chat sind
einmal red 0 punkte blue 0 punkte den
boost der staat bei 100 und wenn ich
allerdings drücke dann weht schon geht
der boost runter und dadurch werde ich
halt schneller durch den muss dann kann
ich mir nicht linksklick drücke kann er
richtig brücke kann ich springen und
wenn ich das ding und in der haut da
drin habe in der mitte kann ich halt mit
doppelsprung sondern frontflip machen
und wenn ich den links ab mache ich halt
zeit flechten rechts ab mache ich halt
zum rechten flipper mitspringen kann
dementsprechend schneller der blaue
davon ist krankhafter und ich habe jetzt
gar nicht mehr sondern wir spieler
trocknet league und und oh mein gott wo
hacker direkt altersklasse crafter de
abonniert
haye hat es nicht wir talente alter nein
nein nein als ob man sein tier könnte ja
das war rückwärts eigentor kann man hier
auch an der decke fahren eigentlich yao
tatsache nein ich bin an deck array
maschine vollen winkel eltern
ich hasse auch dieses rocket sich jetzt
direkt reinigte ihn jetzt so toll an
hallo ich fahre mal gegen den ball oder
passiert man niemals nein man von rain
isabella das nicht ihr aufgenommen
was ist das denn was soll das denn
wahrscheinlich kriegst du den ball als
erstes lass mir einen ballkontakte dann
dann hab ich den rehbock erwarte
kaufkraft von crafter com kraft doch
nein weil du machst du bestimmt 60
aber wie extra stein sein die auch wenn
es aus dem was ist das denn man das kann
auch nicht sein dieses spiel verteilt ja
da ist doch da ja glatt rocket liebe
games endet red wings laut des lach
hundertprozentig am team wehrt sich
gegen ein team blau okay ich in dem
jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal das blaue
team bis daten da mal eben das match
aber das ist doch klar ich bin team
klauen muss jetzt auf der ein toller
hinten sonst würden wir doch auch nicht
so spawnen leben aber soll
ein raster was nicht gestimmt hat der
ball ist irgendwie nicht so freuen von
diesen ecken habe ich das gefühl das ist
aber gar kein ding für luca denn der
duca berührt den ball und dann geht er
doch schon direkt ins tor schoss das
kosovo willen ein schnäppchen
wieso hab ich nicht rein gemacht und wir
sind chef gedrückt das geworden
hey man arm nicht mehr so max mir leid
okay wir waren noch eine letzte runde
ich bin wieder team blau du bist dem rot
scheiße
ok jetzt der verlierer jetzt muss er
bald rostock ii inso warum nicht er geht
die idee ja muss um eine rein gehen
jetzt kommt also scheiß ball fleck fleck
kommen ball kommen verriet storm
wachstum vor der aufnahme schon gesagt
dass das spiel locker 0 0 ausgeht ja
nein ja da muss es sein
mainz nicht bekommen bald neujahr
gewonnen bin immer nur wird diese wohl
wird gesorgt
was dazu beigetragen okay ich mache
jetzt eine hexe was auch wie ich heute
eben mein heck an sondern ist alles in
ordnung hier wasser schafkopf das
gesehen und cool
ich bin im tor jugendlich dabei ist echt
er hat dann seine eigene sein eigenes
leben irgendwie der geht rein oder
anstehenden retten alba großer ball im
gerettet werden
neuer alter ich verstehe dass immer
niveau dieser ball hinfliegt er hat hier
einfach überhaupt keine
doch wozu er jedoch dazu ohne gott nein
er muss noch mal ich hab nur noch 60
sekunden altern ein ja meine hacks
wirken jetzt jetzt geht's richtig ab
nein nein gesagt ja danke hacker foren
for life und meiner mom und alle
möglichen die mich dabei auf diesem weg
unterstützen
es ist so toll dass ihr immer auf meiner
seite sein 321 kopf schon freunde dass
man mit rocket liegt zusammen mit max
wenn es euch gefallen hat würden wir uns
über eine bewertung freuen
dann werden wir definitiv eine party
schmeißen alter monats tief
und 5